but he threw it in the wrong place to
the wrong man and that was a dean D John
Johson and did you see how he stood
there to make sure you got everyone's
attention the man is
back look at you with the swag too I'm
putting it on the on they added two more
in the third for that six run third now
Bryce Harper situation we all saw what
happened at the end of game two base
running mistake doubled up at first game
over Braves win there were reports out
there and a story circulating out there
that after the game um Orlando Aria
cackled
emphatically after Harper was doubled up
word was he was in the clubhouse saying
at a boy Harper at a boy Harper um
[Music]
and he heard he heard about this that's
all that's all I'm going to say he was
made aware of
that
so there's here's the shot we just
talked about second deck and the uh
stare what' you say out a boy what you
say RC looking down won't make eye
contact
later straightway center
[Applause]
field I here you go oh uh hello hey Alan
how are you boy I'm going let you know
I'm here but you saw how he played it
off when he talked to Matt Wier just
play a baseball game you see that but
what I did like is rcia finally gave him
contact some eye contact the second time
around and you should if you're going to
say something then let him know oh
reminds me when AI stepped over Tyron
Lou let him know something yeah little
man messing with a Big Dog hey you asked
for the boss so they sent me dog did you
see coach Jimmy back
there I look at Andrew McCutchen had a
boy Harper ooo had a boy yeah look they
had a chance to let the Phillies really
just walk away fing down and it's not
unusual to hear guys in the club out
saying something about like that
something like that it wasn't said
directly to a reporter but it was heard
and I'm glad it was because the East the
Braves who's been who've been great for
so long winning the divisions and the
Phillies just kind of more like a
respectful rivalry we saw what happened
earlier with uh the bird and thean and
Thompson and then that happens you're
talking about lighting a fire under a
team who was ready not that they're
ready to pack it in but ready to take
that air that plane ride and kind of
feel a little bad what
happened that came out we don't know
they knew what it did to them it lit a
fire they came out castanos hitting
bombs two Bryce with two um Trey with
one Marsh it was like you put him to
sleep and then you going to go turn
around and wake him back up you got to
watch out especially when the media is
in the locker room we can have fun we
can joke we can say whatever it is we
want but there's always someone in there
with the camera and a live live with the
feet recording it so go to the bathroom
go to the training room or make sure
they are gone before we go ahead and
have our fun and this is an example of
it yeah there's an old baseball adage
that no longer replies about the about
the clubhouse what you see here what you
say here what you hear here it stays
here when you leave here and that's no
longer the case uh and so Bryce Harper
knew um very well what had gone on in
the brave Clubhouse after that game and
uh every one of this that we have it's a
camera it's a
microphone is exposure and that's the
difference between the times that we
played and now everyone wants to
be out there everyone wants to say
something everybody everyone wants to
have an opportunity to expose himself
about whatever they want to express uh
we we will probably sit down in the
clubhouse back in my days grab a beer
wait for everybody to go and we'll we'll
sit down in the clubhouse and say
whatever we needed to say about anybody
when it's just the team's ears in there
yeah but when you have media and you
have social media sometimes you're
talking right here but I have my phone
over here recording everything all the
time and that's that's what happened
that's why it's so so much more
difficult nowadays to deal with the this
anything in baseball because every
single phone out there every microphone
it it's out there especially during the
postseason and that's exactly what the
media wants to
see I've been part of it I I've been
part of New York and once we had a
microphone up on top of the ceiling in
in New York and then I remember not too
long ago the Yankees went by the the the
clubhouse playing New York New York with
the speaker right with the speaker and
then all of a sudden the the Red Sox put
it on the Yankees and they go play New
York New York so it you just got to be
careful you just have to kind of uh be a
professional let that go play the game
beat him up and then you can brag about
but for us I'm glad it happened Pedro
yeah yeah has that little spark I mean
regardless regardless who wins it's
nothing like having teams that really
dislike each other not on a personal
level like I don't even like way that
uniform looks the colors what it
represents it is fun to have that and I
think we're starting to see that between
the two team how about Chris pass
pitchers love it when position players
on your own team it's off the Superstar
hitters on the other
team that is that is well put well
Strider it's going to be much louder
make it loud tomorrow I love as if this
rivalry needs any more spice you get
this thing going with Harper and Aria
you got Philadelphia fans doing the chop
saying we want Strider we want Strider
and they'll they'll get him in in game
four but you know what be careful what
you ask for yeah be careful what you ask
for and that's exactly what happened
probably with Garcia they know that they
were the better team during the regular
season now they made you know a huge
comeback last night to come back and and
win that game and and
then something like this pops up
especially going into Philly momentum
was killed right there as soon as they
started that game momentum was killed
now if you're asking for a Strider and
Strider goes up out there and pictures a
jam for the for the Atlanta Braves be
careful what you asked for because it
could reverse the curse hey you know
what we haven't talked about as far as
this game goes yet Aaron Nola Aron no
can we talk about his can we talk about
his start tonight paper yes I would love
to say that he was outstanding it
started the game really aware what he
needed to do which was Pitch not really
throw the ball around pitch if you watch
the the the the first sequences that he
worked against these guys was just pitch
pitch and once he got ahead he was able
to elevate that fast ball and then
dropped the hmer on them he did it all
night and they couldn't realize but that
was because EJ he was able to command
and make quality pitches early in the
game the first two innings was like
pinpoint control boom Picasso on the
corners boom boom boom being really
cautious and staying away from a number
or maybe a long ball early in the game
to build the momentum for Atlanta so
Aron no pitch today like an experienced
pitcher and someone that really
understood what the situation was and we
talk about experience remember in the
pregame we mentioned all of the Atlanta
hitters and the number of bats they face
Nola and what advantage they might have
Nola is taking notes too I faced you I
faced you I faced you you had success in
this okay I need to do something
different this time and we saw that
tonight like you said Pedro Elevate when
I need to maybe so and so struggled
against the the up fast ball then I go
back down against somebody who might
have had success against the fast ball
so they're also Gathering that knowledge
too and we saw Nola do that tonight and
execute perfectly five and two3 six hits
two runs struck out nine walked one